all right Michelle Michelle where'd you
grow up were you from originally
oh the valley San Fernando Valley yes
until I bought your show that you had
you had both your parents as a kid yeah
until I was 11
what happened to living Thanks my
parents split up went to go live with my
uncle which is my mom's brother and
everything downhill from there what kind
of stuff happened then well I was the
baby and my brother he's the oldest and
then my sister at the mill job and being
the baby they're more vulnerable so
being young I was molested and raped
every other night by my uncle my mom was
too busy trying to take care of three
kids schoolwork she was never really
home my brother he's oldest so he's out
partying and stuff my sister she
basically went off with her friends put
her nose in a book and just like in her
own little world so being the youngest
my uncle I guess knew it was easy to
take advantage of me so told me if I
ever said anything you know he'd kick my
whole family on the street they'll
abandon me he put me up for adoption and
everything if I got my mom and my
brother my sister kicked all the houses
so so to protect the family you did
because yeah I had to keep a secret
until I was 17 and then you know met my
soul mate so to speak got pregnant moved
out of the house I had my little baby
girl and then I got pregnant again I
wasn't having a boy but I got stressed
out one day you know due to a death in
the family and I had a miscarriage at
five months nonetheless and there's your
second child on the way there's gonna be
a boy mm-hmm
so what happened then the miscarriages
my baby was already so big they had to
cut my baby up inside me and pull him
out unfortunately when they cut him out
they accidentally a little bit of my
uterus so I can never have kids skin and
that broke my heart
nonetheless I lost my baby and he was so
upset about it he went and when does
something stupid he did a drive-by with
a couple of his friends because he was
so drunk and so mad and he didn't pull
the trigger
from my understanding what he told me
but he did do one thing he hid the gun
and while hiding the gun his
fingerprints were on it so they raided
the house when they found the gun and
they took him to jail for nonetheless
murder so so this was your boyfriend or
husband and I saw me that time yeah I
was going to marry him got engaged had
my baby girl everything was just going
so perfect and when he went to jail you
know court proceedings every weekend I
did my best and they scented him 25 life
so I lost him in the process I started
doing drugs again I started I lost
almost everything my girl however I gave
custody to my family so your daughter is
Christina right exactly
yeah she's a big girl now you know I did
the best I could with her even though
she was in their custody I took care of
her you know regardless of a drug habit
whatnot and she had you know everything
Christina who people have seen on my
channel
she's 16 though yeah she's a big girl
and she's where is she who raised her um
me and my mom she did cuz my mom finally
moved out and got
our own place so gave custody to my mom
I think Christina is on the street now
yeah like a mom
yeah she likes you know she's wild she
likes to venture out and yeah she's
doing good she's off and off you know
jobs and everything she tries so I mean
I can't be mad at her she's a smart girl
very very and you guys have any kind of
relationship now oh yeah she comes she
finds me she talks to me you know we go
on a little outing so every time when
she comes so we have a good relationship
with her yeah very good she knows what I
do I don't keep no secrets from her you
know mm-hmm yeah we get along just fine
so she's your one and only yeah my only
one I can't have no more I think your
drug is crack mmm yeah
and you've been using it steadily ever
since yeah ever since that incident yeah
did you
do you look this you know like like your
daughter's living on the street you're
living on the street
your childhood was was certainly not
perfect it's almost like a chain of
destruction that just keeps going on and
on and on yeah I think if I would have
been there home with her she would never
right yeah or if your mom was yeah your
parents hadn't split up and the fewer
Mama's and I wouldn't be in this
position but you know things happen its
life and just because my emotional
breakdown you know everything went to
hell
so today you're working as a prostitute
on Skid Row yeah tonight gets dangerous
right it does I almost lost my life like
twice there's some of the guys that pick
you up mmm I hear that a lot you have to
be really careful you get arrested
sometimes well I haven't got arrested in
quite a few years cuz I don't I don't
try and be out there as much as I do but
I mean
what do you think would help Christina
what do you think would be the right
thing for her that's I think she should
go back to school because she is very
very smart and just you know her little
habits she needs to ease up on them a
little bit but I don't want to be a
hypocrite and I mean I'd done the same
thing and it would be wrong if I'm still
doing the same thing telling her not to
you know mommy does it so why can't I
but that's why I'm going trying little
by little to change everything my
housing is just going through and she's
living in a tent currently yeah and as
soon as I get stabled with that she's
coming with me
maybe maybe her getting her life
together might help her mom yeah very
much I have make sacrifices what's that
what's the worst thing about having a
childhood that's as unstable as yours
was it's just like you never feel you
can you don't you don't feel anything
it's like a nightmare every day and I
mean I've done some stuff cutting I
burned myself everything and I kept
telling myself wake up wake up this is
nightmare this is not your life wake up
almost every other day I was so angry I
had to keep a secret for so long
but throughout when she was growing up I
told my mom don't let any anybody near
her and like I said I did my best to be
around more often than out here and I
didn't let anybody it's her so she
wouldn't be like me and have that so
really terrible experience yeah the
stuff you went through it impacts your
self-worth and makes you almost not able
to accept okay a better life or a better
partner or a better job or a better
anything right right it's like a curse
that just follows you everywhere you go
yeah and then drugs gonna come in the
picture and then they become hard to
break and yeah but I mean it's bad and I
should try something else but it's just
that that's the only thing that keeps me
in my body it's like it keeps me from
not to feel that all that pain that I
have but you were clean when you had
Christina yeah I was yes and your life
was pretty well I mean I'm sure you were
still dealing with some stuff from your
childhood did yes still I'm still
dealing with things from my childhood
and I'm very very overprotective and
first the most part she had a good life
for the most part except for being out
here but I said as soon as this goes
through she's out of here
she's still young yeah she is and I want
her to have the ability to have a better
life and to change all this
so this you have a plan
and it's already in motion so so where
would that be on the skid row or in skid
row
well the first starting out that you
know plan is on skid row because you
have to go through SROs and then you
know become section eight but now the
things are going with the corona thing
they're more likely to give you
spiritually off the tops so it's it's
moving it's going a lot better do and
section a is anywhere in the county so
we don't have to be in downtown well
that's great and getting away from here
the drugs my team all right exactly
do something different yeah maybe you
guys can help each other yeah I think I
need her just as much as she needs me
all right Michelle thank you so much for
coming in and talk with me mm-hmm
good luck with uh with everything it
sounds like a good plan
thank you thank you
you